maritime archaeologist Gary Malmberg has
been exploring these waters for 20 years
thank you
the English Channel is a notoriously
difficult place to dive meticulous
preparations are vital
visibility isn't great so be careful
cool buddy up together and I'll take you
to put on the shop line see the seabed
and then I'll take you to the site
No
with powerful tides and cold water
conditions are treacherous but at the
bottom of this line lies a treasure
trove from another age
[Music]
well it's unlucky that man you cannot be
seen making a few feet
[Music]
so a tree 8,000 years ago sea levels
were lower and the seabed was dry land
the wood has survived underwater for
millennia the trees are all part of a
preserved a hunter-gatherer landscape
it's a struggle against the current to
get to the main site
well
there is some kind of structure our man
looks like lawyers at the word just
taking you out of the suit
[Music]
the clues in a dad like you sitting in
an ancient ghost town but underwater
we take some samples to get a better
idea of what this is back on the boat
that's incredible
looks like there's a whole platform down
there it's layered one piece on top of
the other almost like looks like a dock
hopefully wool oh it's cold down there
and murky but it's incredible you know
you just send down this line and out of
the darkness what comes the ancient past
you can see here
how this piece of wood could be locked
in time in the ocean how does that
happen where it doesn't decay well
what's happened with this is that as the
sea levels risen above it it's covered
in it with his silt and it's taken over
the oxygen and it just preserved it in a
sort of anaerobic oxygen-free
environment and it would have stayed
there for many more thousand years but
recently the old landscapes are eroding
away which is how we found this well and
what is that that is not this yeah what
is it for that little piece that
stretches back a little bit broken their
neck is a peg that comes back over the
next piece it looks like it's just to
help fix the thing in place it's a
composite structures like this it is of
international significance it's 8,000
years old
you still just get this every day can
you describe to me the seen one of this
would have existed with him
this was next to a stream and we know as
a bit of a wetland so it could have been
a nice support could have been a
platform could have been a pontoon we
don't know yet
we don't know because there's nothing
else like it in the country Wow and it
was somewhere where we found what we
believe to be the oldest boat building
site in the world where they would have
built a canoe and longbow so that's what
they would sales
[Music]